oh I'm playing this guy this guy is also
a London specialist I wonder what he
plays against the London oh we got Rosen
some King's Indian thing remember we we
played a London before he knows what's
coming too and myself is this is this
where we're supposed to stop E5 okay but
Eric and I have also played this slime
let's go into the the line
like he he's really really knows how to
prosecute this line and this is a
world's leading expert so I'm walking
into my eventual
demise here last time we went into the
cpme so
maybe some shots I suppose we'll play
this again I think Rook B3 is a move
but yeah more and more players are uh
let's say becoming familiar with uh with
this line which is not I'm like already
I think I enjoy it too much of a risk
but Knight C4 Queen G7 it's like why'd
you have to go and take the final number
did you just be happy being up a lot of
material
did you have to go and analyze it as
well
or maybe a rookie geez
rookie three is safer okay
Rook E3 is interesting I mean it's
definitely not Rook B5 which I'm more
used to
like the only time in my life I beat Ali
Reza was it from a very similar position
it was a Lee chess bullet game I I was
like single or double adopted
but then Holly Reza went a little bit
too far and played this line so I'm
throwing F4 but I also just want to take
and transform the position and triple
Fork
get my queen as a wooden Shield I feel
like that's called The Wooden Shield
pow bing boom
boom quad that's the wooden Shield
because F4 I think we'll see king of
seven feels like it makes too much sense
yeah I mean this line is supposed to
seem like such a good move
it's risky to play especially let's try
that one I think it makes sense I'm
digging with increments
this one right away takes takes
um
series it moves in in this it's always
like
the biggest uh
question mark in the opening
man I had such a similar at least we
keep the bishop and we cover
I don't know a few squares that uh the
Knight may want to use
start with a check
I know this looks insane
but I want to go here next and if he
checks me I go back
if he covers that you know so now this
and of course none of it makes sense but
maybe King D7 with D3 coming next
Bishop D3 is coming next to play Bishop
A5 initiative that's an important
question
we're all wondering
because we'd love to just yeah long
Castle
but obviously the Knight is being hit
foreign
we can make it just as annoying for him
and go here
Bishop here we have to move
there's a line
hard to make it work though
singing about King D7
H3 first
page seven maybe Rook here
H3 G4
okay obviously we've gotta go
if we go somewhere we have to watch this
against our will
I have this pin that's about it me too
delayed bomb cloud
hmm
Bishop C3
still have to be careful
okay ah
three one was at least playable I kind
of hung upon but I don't know I guess we
were a little too slow there damn that's
how you beat the unbeatable England
Gambit